up next is a hunter and Joey in Texas Oh
HJ hunter and Joey you want to HJ that's
the initials of them Oh what's up
showers you want to live living life in
prison or you wanna die yeah sounds like
these ones thing about robbing a bank
[Music]
that video these boy these always are
they're gonna commit a crime weighing in
what we think they should do yeah we've
got a prisoner list our lives you got
firing I mean what do you guys think man
yeah shout out today where are they from
Texas Bob Jones lemonade oh dude Mike's
hella hard lemonade that had a [ __ ]
man's dick in it boys were hammered so
it's a couple of beautiful young fellas
out there man a couple of young full of
testosterone and yes bro yeah but some
good guys out there drinking liquor in a
garage or something yeah gather you know
what I'm saying always thinking about
doors unibrow probably thinking about
their spouses or something or thinking
about the things are thinking about
robbing a bank okay um a couple of and J
with those but with those bank robber
ideas life and prisoner die young [ __ ]
man you want to go first you want me to
look I'll go life in prison cuz here's
the thing you get to try and break out
what's fun or like there's sometimes
there's people in prison their whole
life they never tried to break out
you're in [ __ ] prison dudes all you
have to do so it's fun yeah didn't you
ever play that game when you were young
they tag you you go back to the jail and
you [ __ ] get out yeah dude tell my
freeze tag right here yeah also there's
you've seen the show Prison Break you're
seeing Shawshank Redemption yeah [ __ ]
looks fun yeah Brooks was here dude now
he's gay
daddy you know dude find you a red come
up with a plan and get the [ __ ] out boys
yeah shoot the warden papa
yeah we're shoe shine his shoes you
could have math write a letter to the
library every day order club bro m/s 14
papa yeah do me dude what gaming Benny
way about what gang would we join in
prison I'm tough you're an exabyte but I
don't think that area natured let me
hear you actually you're Aryan I would
go Mexican you [ __ ] me they're not
gonna let you in yeah they would I would
knock in my face oh I've dyed my facial
hair you'd have to go just a mustache
and I would wear short pants and I would
walk real low to the ground shorter like
a cholo and go Mexican you do I do do
and I get a huge button on the top of my
shirt at the top so it would focus on
that one like oh he's definitely one of
us look at his button I'd have to I
don't know I'd have to whiten it up no
you have to chop your legs off you have
to get in a wheelchair because if they
see a tall [ __ ] dude yeah they're
like oh you should be in the UFC you're
getting B mmm everybody's gonna [ __ ]
somebody these two fight for a living
you got you're gonna get one at all
yeah I know they want another trained on
me Oh naughty broke I'm scared
getting sexed up isn't really that bad
but some God just you're gonna get snow
they're gonna be dudes holding your hand
oh dude like I never hold guys pockets
around the yard for you have to learn to
eat lunch with your left handed cuz I'm
just gonna behold I'm like this the
whole time I know you're a trade [ __ ]
cigarette for [ __ ] oatmeal Pie for
Sam brow for neosporin bro it treats
cigarettes were banded he loves stressed
let me trade some cigarettes for some
shoe polish do llama I'm gonna go uh die
die young I want to die young are you
dude you wanna be in prison too late
yeah with that here you know they're
[ __ ] your face bro I'm alive in
prison though not really you're
basically dead dude you've seen a lining
zoo did they look very alive to you
they're dead behind the eyes dude they
still run free and change it and kill
now you go to the zoo they're just
they've given up but at you in prison
bro
especially that pretty mouth your
[ __ ] stupid haircut there [ __ ] facing
you dude uh-uh no they won't do that
it's science bro it ain't science
brother not in its where you're gonna be
a sister no I'm not doing all that do
you don't have a choice they'll probably
do ours
can't fight either huh yeah I can bro no
you're biting my legs now with my arms
that good that makes sense
I'm going to die young yeah do whatever
you want to you're dead go out I'm fine
so I will probably break out and after I
help raise your family raise your son I
appreciate dude wait 80% say die young
as well do you know how hard it is to
break out of prison huh
no at least I'll have a chance to find
help dead guy I don't want to fine I
don't know the result
hey where's Brendan are dead they were
still in prison in prison but he might
show up randomly one night 40 years
hopefully broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching